this video is sponsored by skillshare
you know what the difference is between
this blank page and this beautiful work
of art creativity well that and skill
and required materials but it starts
with creativity that exists in every
human being if you've ever wanted to
draw or write or act or edit videos or
do anything creatively artistic then boy
oh boy am i excited to talk to you about
skillshare see skillshare is an online
learning community with literally
thousands of classes designed to inspire
people to do amazing things i was given
the awesome opportunity to try
skillshare out and found myself really
learning from the productivity for
creatives class with thomas frank and
what's cool is that since skillshare is
curated specifically for learning there
are never any ads in the class videos if
you're interested in taking the first
step or the next step in your creative
journey then please take some time to
click the link in the description below
the first 1 000 people to do so will
receive a one month free trial of
skillshare's premium membership and now
onto the video
[Music]
hey everyone bandit here as a lot of you
already know the widely anticipated
september direct was released to us just
a couple days ago and i say a lot of you
not all because statistically speaking
there are still a lot of people out
there who have still not seen the
nintendo direct if you look at the views
on the watch page weird but anyway this
direct pretty much smashed through
everybody's expectations for not only
the content that it talked about but it
was also scripted and paced and executed
very well even for nintendo standards
here are 10 reasons why i personally
feel like this was one of the best
nintendo directs ever one the direct was
packed with announcements with very
little down time in between their bigger
titles if you've seen my reaction video
you know that i was constantly like
checking my watch going okay it's only
been 10 minutes 15 minutes 20 minutes
but like in a good way because i really
liked everything that i was seeing and i
couldn't believe that there was that
much time left because knowing nintendo
they leave their big stuff for the end
kind of like a marvel movie all in all i
never felt like i wanted to skip over
segments even when they were going over
like the indie titles even those were
interesting there was plenty to read and
react to two they opened up the direct
with monster hunter rise sun break now
for long time fans of the monster hunter
series you know that this is a big deal
10 years ago i would have never imagined
a monster hunter game opening up
nintendo's direct which means that this
is a great testament to just how far the
series has come which i think was in
large part due to monster hunter world's
success which ironically wasn't even on
a nintendo console but not only did
monster hunter open up the show it was
about an expansion to monster hunter
rise their newest game which is on the
nintendo switch this resonated really
well with me because while i love
monster hunter rise and all the new
hunter moves that came with it and the
doggos that you can ride the main
problem that i had with the game and the
main reason why i haven't finished it
yet is because i felt like there weren't
many monsters in the game monster hunter
rise sun break however is the solution
to this problem because it's going to be
adding
at least one new monster so there's that
three
there's a new kirby game coming out it's
3d so not only do you move this way and
this way but you move
all the ways okay and it looks like it's
gonna be open world which is an entirely
new experience for any kirby game ever
and since the previous title kirby star
allies was
okay kirby in the forgotten land is
looking very welcome and very intriguing
so far if anything just for all the new
theory material
four obviously as far as new games are
concerned we ended the direct with the
bomb drop of bayonetta 3 which has been
being asked for by fans since bayonetta
2 which was like six or seven years ago
so yeah it's been quite a while now i'm
not even a bayonetta fan really i mean
i've barely even played as her and smash
brothers but even i know this is a huge
deal nothing but good hack and slash
witchery to come i'm sure the way the
trailer revealed her after making people
think that it was like a sequel to
astral chain 2 with that dog balloon
thing and then having her jump in there
and say that super witty thing that she
says it seems i'm unfashionably late
bravo nintendo bravo five the nintendo
64 is coming to the switch online
services now
i know that this being a good thing is
debatable i mean on pretty much any
social media platform that you go on
youtube twitter whatever fans are pretty
divided on this subject on the one hand
you have fans that are excited to replay
and relive these old classics again on a
new home console experience without
having to bother with the old consoles
or emulators or anything like that but
on the other hand you have the fans that
are
actually quite livid about the entire
affair for several reasons such as one
that nintendo would wait to release this
until just now or two that nintendo
would charge us extra for it or three
that other fans are excited about it
because re-releasing old content is bad
right now on that note i'm not gonna
comment on nintendo's business practices
because listen
businesses are gonna business okay and
drama and debating over it is just
exhausting and quite frankly not what i
do here so i'm not gonna make a
statement on it but what i will say is
this if you don't want to support it
don't buy it but don't stomp on people
who are excited for it let people be
happy about things you don't know
everyone's story you don't know how news
is going to impact every other person
you don't know what they've experienced
everyone is entitled to their own
opinions and everybody having different
opinions is what makes variety in life
and variety is the spice of life and
spice is nice you're welcome the reason
why i think this is a good thing
personally is because there are so many
nintendo fans out there who have not
experienced the classics
it's true and these people are not
really going to care enough to go buy an
old overpriced old console from joe
schmo on ebay and then buy an old tv to
hook up said old console with or on the
flip side set up an emulating system and
get a universal controller on their
computer it just doesn't sound that
attractive all to play what games over
20 years old like i said before this is
the answer to that and it is literally
bringing some of the greatest games to
have ever been created on the current
home console of the switch with added
multiplayer both couch and online which
has never been experienced officially
before yes i definitely wish that it was
included before now and i do wish that
it wasn't necessarily for an additional
cost but it is what it is six
ditto to everything i just said but for
the sega genesis which i'm pretty sure
nobody was expecting to come to the
switch listen with this edition in
addition to the nintendo 64 online you
do realize now that your switch is going
to be the one stop shop where you can
switch from playing super metroid to the
original super mario brothers to super
mario 64 to ocarina of time to freaking
the original metroid to sonic the
hedgehog all in one console in one
sitting with optional multiplayer and
instant save states all streamed from
the cloud so there's no download
required it's not wrong to be happy
about this moving on though number seven
miyamoto popped up now for those of you
who have seen nintendo directs in the
past which i'm assuming is all of you
you know that miyamoto doesn't normally
pop up unless it's like really really
big
like the super mario movie for instance
now again if you saw my reaction video
then you know that my initial reaction
to the cast list was
not exactly a good one but since then
i've had some time to think about it and
laugh about it and i've come to terms
with it and i've even developed somewhat
of an excitement for the movie if you
will
oh my anyway the fact that miyamoto
popped up to reveal what they knew was
going to be kind of a controversial
point is very very calculated and
meticulous in my opinion because look
they knew that people were gonna watch
that and be all like
what the frick nintendo so they brought
out mr nintendo himself a familiar
friendly face to help ease the pain and
calm people down a little bit as much as
he could anyway also his hair was
freaking fabulous eight this direct gave
us a whole bunch to look forward to next
month in october so not only is metroid
dredd releasing next month which we
already knew about but the nintendo 64
and sega genesis services are coming
online next month as well in addition to
that we have the promise of a sakurai
direct where he's going to reveal the
last smash character finally which is
definitely going to make everybody happy
and we have an animal crossing direct
coming next month which is very welcome
because for a lot of fans um we kind of
forgot that the game exists or maybe
that's just me maybe maybe i'm the only
one who forgot that it existed i'm sorry
tom nine the legend of zelda was covered
in hyrule warriors now i don't think
anybody was really expecting for breath
of the wild sequel to be covered in this
specific direct especially because just
a few months ago we had a brand new
trailer dropped for breath of the wild 2
and we had the release of skyward sword
hd which were both pretty big all things
considered but for the zelda fans out
there we did have the familiar faces of
link zelda the rest of the champions and
even a little screaming angry baby sidon
to gaze upon since age of calamity is
getting what looks to be a pretty big
story expansion complete with entire
cutscenes featuring i guess the entire
original voice cast even though we
didn't have a specific zelda section of
the direct it was still really nice for
it to not only be mentioned but straight
up covered which is no doubt exciting
for those who enjoy hyrule warriors
gameplay finally at number 10
splatoon 3 had an incredible new trailer
that showed off some new details for the
game so far that has had fans just i
mean it's been a smash hit and i'm not
really a splatoon fan by the way that's
not on purpose necessarily i just
haven't really gotten around to playing
one of the games but from what i can see
from the outside looking in if you will
return of the mammalians has gotten a
lot of fan favorite characters and lore
returning in the three quill if you will
it's a big deal trust me if you need
proof just look at that video's comment
section and that's my list about the top
10 amazing things about this recent
direct but what did you guys think was
it something i missed or maybe
misinterpreted let me know in the
comments below also humongous thanks to
everybody for watching if you would
leave a like on the video if you liked
the video really helps with stuff like
the algorithm and subscribe to the
channel if you haven't already for much
more nintendo stuff to come and dear
bandit crew i love you thank you all so
much for going above and beyond in
supporting the channel and please say
hello to the new face of kdb who
recently joined the ranks of my elite if
you're interested in doing the same the
join button is right below my face
literally it's right there that's all
i've got for this one so as always i
hope you have a wonderful rest of your
day this is maskington abandoned looking
forward to seeing you in the next one
and signing out peace
[Music]
you